walk in to this video playing dark virus
here with black it's a feeling master
let's see what we get to get at this
line which is normally quite ok for
black leading to two decent player there
are some scenarios i get d for for a
piece I plays deform CD Queen takes 96
wear black gets a good development let's
see what he here to choose us yep the
development version and very often I go
eat six Bishop before Queen f6 getting
quick development check
I might run into 94 quickly I wonder if
this was a very precise move order
really with bishop before check but ok
nothing nothing terrible has happened i
think
yeah I still have a good development
takes him yeah maybe do it like that
keep it keep it simple anyway if he
takes I'm in very decent shape with a
very good structure actually it looks
weird with the double porn but
everything's okay c4 is the target i got
Queen B 6 coming he will probably not
take me she didn't okay yeah I thought
d5 should be good let's just let's just
play quickly for a change not losing on
time you have the last couple of games
really showed that I also play bad news
when I take my time so should maybe just
play quick once and hope that they're
better yeah get some crazy pre moves and
come on you're going to take on d5
anyway at the end and now you're going
to take on a five and on d5 yep and I'm
getting a an endgame here with the pawn
but it's a it's a passer okay look here
so that I can also go on the beep on
yeah I want to get my king involved here
of course like every porn and every rook
endgame there is some serious tendency
for a draw here I can give the check or
the city move okay it's just it's not
terrible but not not helping in any way
you could be 60 k 5 it's it's not
mattering much I have king is 6
yeah i mean i don't i don't have any
problem here i just think of do I have
some ideas to to play this for win i
feei don't trying but
check
hmm this is this is curious isn't this a
bit risky in public for why Tommy with a
5 may be coming and look be to this is a
king assassin a slightly slightly tricky
audio now kept this must be right anyway
let's not overthink it here I'm play it
anyway at the end takes root be too with
the main thread and f2 attacked
I wonder if he takes can i play King c5
is this may be an idea the threads this
is actually strong it threatens rook
takes a five check Andrew ka checkmate
aha this is this is much better than
look B to King c5 let's just check for a
moment I have some time on the clock
very very uncommon but I have some time
here yeah threatening rook air-five
that's really neat with made into yeah
you can check that's cute yeah
white resigns yeah then a five was even
stronger than I thought I was initially
I was intending this which is quite nice
yeah the the maid threat and the rook
attacks the porn but King c5 is winning
winning directly and this means that
after a five white is in big trouble I
don't really see a move to be honest now
he has the moves i'm i'm i'm just good
i'm just winning before you hi
interesting yeah in this room in this
rook endgame I think Joe is the fair
result but of course your check can
still try these ideas here with rookie
five are really not not helping I mean
after this we get to the position with a
five and here why does i think lost I
mean you can go here but isn't the king
and porn and came just to win check we
look at this check here he is running
out of moves I just have this this is
essentially an extra pawn yeah funny a5
was a very cute maneuver okay thanks for
watching